what's going on there reject nation greg
and john back at it to talk about more
multiverse of madness action i think
it's safe to say that deadpool is
confirmed to appear in multiverse of
madness we got things from what rob
liefeld talked about a couple days ago
what he said on twitter and also we want
to talk about what his role could
possibly be in this movie so before we
go into it off you guys can hit that
like button and that would be very much
appreciated so let's talk about how it's
been confirmed first things first a few
days ago over at the big thing with
christian harloth and koi zhandra they
were interviewing rob and in case you
guys don't know rob livefield creator of
deadpool so co-created x-force and cable
accidentally kind of confirmed some
things before even the trailer came out
and this was fun to peek through you can
watch the video over at the big thing
karloff and coy both obviously friends
of ours when talking about cameos and
such rob said i think it's safe to say
some of the stuff you just said that's
out there it's happening it's in uh it's
been seen and so dude
give us lots of that
but yeah dr strange answer that question
and you know whatever they're testing i
kind of feel like each result of each
test that's being reported in the press
is we need to put more cool [ __ ] in that
movie and then the big thing that he
went on to say was you want me to see it
six times you bring some of that fox
marvel stuff in and actually i know on
some levels some of it is already there
i have just revoked every every one of
my marvel passes just got revoked
so yeah this is before even the trailer
came out with professor x being revealed
in there and then recently on twitter
you know after that thing came out on
the poster of what looks like it could
be deadpool doing the shush sign
comicbook.com put out an article about
it about how deadpool might be featured
on the poster and then roblox i feel
retweeted it and he did three emojis
thinking palm over mouth and then
doing the exact mirroring of what
deadpool was doing there all this to say
it seems like deadpool
is more than likely to be in here it's
been rumored for a while i'm excited
about him being in this what do you
think i'm very excited and i think rob
liefeld is going to have to start
looking for places to write new comics
because
i can imagine just that last thing he
said about his marvel passes is i could
just imagine that he could hear kevin
feige's nerves crunching in that moment
but yeah i mean this seems like a very
cheeky and a very light-hearted
confirmation but certainly a
confirmation nevertheless because as we
saw in the trailer they are bringing in
the fox universe and for all the madness
the one wild card you could absolutely
throw into this movie that has already
been hinted at by kevin feige is
deadpool as much as the original pitch
of that was a little off to me now the
more and more we hear about this movie
the more like yeah deadpool's got to
show up there somewhere and now i'm just
really curious as to how if they're
gonna do coy's theory about having him
kill the fox universe as a means of you
know grafting them on but either way i
think it's gonna be a a blast and i love
that rob liefelda seems very very
enthused about it that seems like a good
sign yeah i mean if anyone could
probably get away with talking about it
this way it's the guy who created
deadpool you know i've been thinking
about the role that he could have you
know i imagine that if half of the
cameos that have been rumored are gonna
be in this movie i gotta imagine a lot
of them are fun winks of the audience i
gotta imagine that a lot of them are
very brief very short you know even in
the trailer itself you have moments
where it looks like they're just
dimension hopping into universes where
you just get like a snippet of a cameo
right that's just kind of the impression
that you're getting that some of them
might not be so substantial just cute
and fun so deadpool could be that he
could just be something really fun just
be like he's officially here guys that
deadpool and cork trailer was not enough
from promoting free guy he's officially
here now he's in an mcu movie i was
thinking about how he could appear or
when he could appear could it be through
dimension hopping because there's been a
lot of discussion about is that
professor x actually the one from the
fox x-men universe or is it professor x
from perhaps the x-men animated series
or just some other universe where the
x-men still exist and professor x is a
part of them that's the one who sits at
the illuminati scene when i'm looking at
the trailer i actually think it might be
a short one but a fun one and and trying
to determine where he could appear i was
thinking it actually could be at the
illuminati headquarters and i was
talking with koi about this when you
know dr strange is imprisoned you know
they have to have a place to keep him
you know arrested and then also as you
see in uh some of the tv spots and as
new rock stars pointed out when you're
going into the eye of scarlet witch it
looks like that's part of the illuminati
prison where perhaps this is what eric
voss was theorizing where you know
wiccan and speed could be held prisoner
so i'm wondering what if it's a cellmate
of doctor strange or someone who's in a
cell near him where he could be there
and there could be other people there as
well where you get some more cameos that
people are being held prisoner there
unlike the tva which seems to want to
prune people right away what if they
have to keep some of them prisoner okay
why would deadpool be there and then
thinking about the events of deadpool 2
where they messed meddling with time and
then even to a certain extent perhaps a
tad bit of multiverse acknowledgement in
deadpool 2 in a metal metal way we're in
the post-credits scene he hops over to
x-men origins wolverine which is clearly
not the canon for the deadpool movies
that we've been getting
where he ends up killing that version of
deadpool had his mouth sewn shut so in
that movie he kind of hopped to another
universe so he could be aware of the
multiverse already and because he can be
considered a multiversal threat due to
that fact they have to just keep him you
know held prisoner perhaps he's had
interactions with professor x and
professor x being a little bit more more
compassionate i would say remember the
professors had to make some rough
choices in his life just think about all
them gene grace stuff we've had to deal
with you know house of m and how they
kind of treated scarlet witch i think it
would be just a fun place to have him
stored or maybe like before that you
know professor x does tell him about
mutants and then he can kind of confirm
and he could be that bridge between it
of being of knowing the existence of
mutants i think that's actually a great
pitch too because if you think of the
idea that maybe the illuminati is a
sinister organization by the end of the
movie too as some people have speculated
deadpool could also be a perfect sort of
character to then escape if the
illuminati were to crumble by the end of
the movie thus setting up you know the
future of him and certain other people
yeah that they would have wanted to
contain because of course they're going
to cause multiversal problems the one
thing i thought they could do is if they
did introduce him in some kind of
universe-hopping way is they could
literally give us a tease of deadpool 3
like in the movie just jump through to a
scene that will later appear in deadpool
3 as if we just kind of walked right
through that movie mid progress or
something like that i don't know if
they're far long enough to do that but i
feel like that could be a fun thing to
then call back on when deadpool 3
actually does come out maybe see the
opposite side of that situation or
something in a cheeky fun way oh like if
we're watching deadpool 3 then you see
like dr strange just having a fight
through a sling ring and they're like
what was that was that okay yeah exactly
make it like a joke but that will come
back and that will establish that yeah
like that really did happen that really
was like a weird just multiversal drop
in really quick or something like that
to then make it more substantial for him
as a specific returning character all
right guys but if deadpool is in here
how would you want him to appear it
looks like it's pretty much confirmed
either way subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
and uh yeah any more multiverse stuff
comes out we're going to want to talk
about it last but not least
david gandy david if there's anyone i
want to traverse the multiverse with it
would be you my friend clearly you love
to travel but you haven't traveled
enough almost every time i talk to you
you're moving someplace or you're trying
to find a new adventure in life to go
explore so when looking at our patreon
who would be the one person to travel
across all kinds of areas of the
universe and who would probably have the
most fond appreciation of it all it's
definitely got to be you you don't seem
like someone who gets scared of too much
overly reactive to things you seem like
the kind of guy who would just want to
snap some photos and have a good time so
david when we go on this adventure i'm
bringing you and i'm leaving you behind
at a terrible place where by the end of
it you'll come back a changed man a
stronger man a buffer man one with like
10 tribal women five additional men all
to be your lovers your mates
and you're gonna thank me